welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and joker 2 aka joker folly a duh
released a new teaser in a release date
october 4th 2024 paulie uh the is an
archaic literal translation of madness
for two but really its modern clinical
definition is shared psychosis it's a
rare syndrome in which a delusional
belief is transmitted from one
individual to another which now seems to
be the case between joaquin phoenix's
joker from todd phillips 2019 film to
this upcoming sequel with lady gaga as
harley quinn yup everything's on fire
over at warner brothers at the moment
when it comes to its dc titles but we
can always count on a billion dollar
oscar winner setting up a sequel team up
with the star of house gucci and a star
is born to set the internet ablaze with
just the best takes on mental health
but let's take a look at this teaser to
begin to explain what this movie even is
roll the clip heaven
i'm in heaven this is eric singing
because this is backup music that
youtube won't let us use in our video
without it get demonetized so here's my
version and we're dancing something
something cheek to cheek
yeah you love it
enjoy those nightmares so this music is
irving berlin's famous cheek to cheek
from the 1935 musical comedy tophat
starring fred astaire and ginger rogers
this is an instrumental section of the
song after fred sings heaven i'm in
heaven and then the two of them go into
a dance break this is what we hear here
we see the silhouette of joaquin phoenix
says arthur fleck one of those shots
when he was suited up in the red orange
and green suit cigarette just dangling
there when in the 2019 film he descended
into one of his many fanciful episodes
but also we see a silhouette of lady
gaga her hair in a bun we're in a dress
with high heels a tiny heart visible on
her cheek actually as these two dance
cheek to cheek the heart on her cheek
nears the joker paint around his eyes
blue triangles above and below here
looking like an up and down button on an
elevator this teaser ends with arthur
releasing his pathological laughter that
he had throughout that 2019 film this
audio actually sounds like it might be
directly from the final scene with him
and arkham with an analyst
what's so funny
remember it was this moment that led
some to suspect that all the events of
the film could have been presented
through the eyes of an unreliable
narrator an interpretation supported by
arthur's romantic relationship with
zzb's character sophie revealed as a
delusion late in the film and that
everything we saw this joker go through
from his talk show massacre to his
ascension to the clown prince of crime
leading a riot that left bruce wayne an
orphan all that might have been the joke
in arthur's mind todd phillips has
confirmed
wanting to preserve the multiple choice
aspect of the joker's backstory from
alan moore's the killing joke and said
that the whole film is really up for
interpretation kind of like fight club
sometimes we're all happy to lose we're
happy to lose our minds over the latest
trailer we're happy to lose our voices
shouting at the latest reveal and we're
happy to lose sight of the bigger
picture because we are obsessing over
the details all part of being a fan but
losing your hair that's different
nobody's happy about that and that's why
there's keeps with keeps you can get
quality expert care without ever having
to visit a doctor's office or a pharmacy
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy though you never have to
go into a doctor's office keeps is a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality whether you're looking to
prevent hair loss stimulate hair growth
or just take better care of the hair
that you have keeps has you covered hair
loss stops with keeps to get 50 off your
first order go to keeps.com new
rockstars or click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash new rockstars now releasing a
concept teaser like this is a lot like
what todd phillips did for that 2019
joker film with a 2018 camera test with
walking phoenix in costume set to the
1969 track laughing by the guess who in
this case this sequel teaser suggests an
interesting tone for joker folly ado
consistent with some of the things that
we've been hearing about it first off
the reports that joker followed might be
a movie musical which would be
consistent with sampling one of the most
famous cinematic movie musical numbers
in hollywood history and the casting of
a movie musical star like lady gaga as
harley quinn gaga's silhouette wearing
high heels is really no coincidence as
there's that famous saying that ginger
rogers had to do everything fred astaire
did but backwards and in high heels that
was my impression of texas governor anne
richards when she did it go watch that
clip that speech was awesome but don't
worry for anyone who might be turned off
of the idea of a musical first off slap
what's wrong with you musicals are
awesome but don't worry it's probably
not what you think it's probably not
going to be characters bursting into
song from out of nowhere or the whole
thing being like an opera where they're
singing throughout no no no no that 2019
joker actually included a musical
sequence if you remember arthur dancing
down the steps to rock and roll part two
which then crossfaded into some of the
darker tones from the film score
[Music]
actually a lot of action movies these
days have these kind of sequences that
are edited to sync with the diegetic
music within the reality of the scene
i've actually made the case that james
gunn's guardians of the galaxy movies in
the mcu are diegetic musicals in that
regard the opening titles of the 2014
film are to peter grill dancing to come
and get your love the 2017 follow-up
groot dances to mr blue sky both of
these movies really dig into the
thematic debate of dancers versus
non-dancers and james gunn even
confirmed to me that the first one of
these movies is meant as a musical love
letter from peter quill's mom to him
we've even seen musical escapism with
the character of harley quinn again with
james gunn his 2021 the suicide squad
showed harley's escape edited to the
rhythm of louis prima's just to gigolo
slash i ain't got no body a song that
harley was singing to herself at the
start of that sequence and before that
2020s birds of prey featured harley when
she was getting wrapped up by roman
sionas's crew escaping into a
reenactment of marilyn monroe's diamonds
are a girl's best friend from gentlemen
prefer blondes so yeah i don't think
we're really looking at a musical in the
vein of a west side story or hamilton
but rather one in which the musical and
the dance sequences are expressions of
the characters shared psychosis their
falia there are other reports that this
movie will be set mostly in arkham
asylum assuming its events pick up as
the 2019 movie ends that actually tracks
if we interpret arthur's bloody
footprints as him having killed that
former analyst arkham might now assign a
new analyst to take her place and that
could be how we get the ambitious dr
harleen quinzel actually whenever i hear
cheek to cheek my mind goes to frank
darabon's 1999 film the green mile in
which the wrongly accused prisoner and a
corrections officer bond over this
specific musical number in top hat i
think of it as a song of a prisoner
imagining his life outside of jail along
with someone who works at that jail
feeling sympathy for him now arthur's
exact mental condition was deliberately
left unspecified in the 2019 film but
with a title like paulia du the sequel
may explore his pathological laughter
being a kind of contagion a
psychological virus that also infects
harley and for the two of them to now
share these delusions the entire sequel
could be set in arkham but have a dual
reality structure a base reality frame
in the mental hospital intercutting with
a musical fantasy with arthur and harley
as the joker and harley quinn running
amuck in their co-imagined gotham and
then gradually populating more and more
of the residents of arkham into this
fantasy by means of their pathological
laughter infecting them as this movie
toggles in and out of their delusions we
would see these patients comic book
fantasy counterparts spreading that
chaos throughout this fantasy gotham now
yes you may be struggling with the idea
of a serialized narrative in which we
know for sure it's really on the
characters imaginations are there any
real stakes in that scenario like for
example marvel studios moon knight
seemed to go in a similar direction in
its fourth episode hinting that steven
grant's superhero awakes were really
part of a delusion in the mind of a
mental patient but then pulled back
again to reveal the hospital as part of
the hero's underworld afterlife
transition and really the hospital part
of it to be a trick coming from his
inner doubt i mean there's still a lot
to interpret from moon knight but really
at the end of the day all the stuff with
the godly possession the invisible
jackals the giant ahmet over cairo all
actually happened in the mcu continuity
but this version of the joker sequel by
contrast would just be unfolding in a
clearly shared delusion now on one hand
that would help warner and dc maintain a
separation between this reality and that
of matt reeves the batman which has its
own gotham and its own joker so they
could go deep into arthroplex
nightmarish imagination without worrying
about how it would all connect to the
robert pattinson bruce wayne journey but
on the other hand one way to give some
real world stakes to arthur and harley's
delusion could be to give this movie a
one flew over the cuckoo's nest style
ending and allow these inmates to
overrun the hospital and break out of it
and infect the broader wider outside
world with this pathological actor
madness for everyone a folly uh
todos i took spanish not french hey let
me know what you think about this
announced joker 2 film follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to new york
stars for more analysis of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you